there's a movie that a lot of people
were watching over the weekend and it
was trending all around
twitter and things like that this is the
tragedy of macbeth
the tragedy of macbeth it was a movie
version based on macbeth by shakespeare
starring denzel washington and frances
mcdormand
and it was slightly controversial
because as you might
recognize denzel washington is not a
particularly well-known scotsman
and the play is about a scottish king
but i decided i was going to sit down
was going to watch the movie
joel cohen one of the greatest living
directors denzel washington one of the
greatest living actors francis mcdormand
one of the greatest living actresses and
macbeth one of the greatest plays ever
written you will be unsurprised to hear
it was a very very good movie and i
thought when i was watching this movie
about an extremely corrupt political
order that is based on treachery
sometimes outright murder that rips the
polity asunder and and leads to horrible
problems for the whole society
i thought huh
this might have something to tell us
about our country today maybe more
people maybe that's the reason they made
the movie in the first place
now
we'll get to more on that in one second
but speaking of movies i'm very excited
to announce the release of the daily
wires first original production we
released a movie that had already been
made last year and we bought the
distribution rights because people were
trying to cancel it so that was our
first movie this is our first original
movie it's called shut in it is a seat
gripping thriller that will be available
to stream in february follows the story
of a young mother who's barricaded
inside a closet by her violent
ex-husband as she's trapped inside
she uses nothing but her voice to guide
her children on the other side of the
walls to safety all while the threat of
her dangerous ex looms so go check it
out it's really cool
uh we cannot wait to share the finished
product with you so make sure you catch
the final trailer when it drops tomorrow
it's gonna be a lot of fun if you're
planning on adding this terrifying
thriller to your queue you want us to
keep making that content that the
mainstream media do not want to produce
then go like and share the trailer on
youtube your support makes all the
difference also we're gonna have
backstage finally again dw is one of the
first in the nation to file suit against
the biden administration on their
unconstitutional osha vaccine mandate
our case made it to the supreme court
and we won tune in tomorrow night to
catch an all-new episode of backstage
where we discuss the outcome of that
supreme court ruling it's going to be
wonderful we're going to drink a lot of
leftist tears it's going to be me ben
jeremy matt and drew 7 p.m 6 p.m central
dailywire.com or
you can stream it on our youtube channel
dailywire
i really loved this movie the tragedy of
macbeth it's kind of an artsy film it's
black and white
it's an ambitious adaptation
it's minimalist and it's set design
but it's it's artsy so if you don't like
artsy movies this is not going to be the
movie for you but it is one of the
greatest plays ever written by the
greatest english playwright with some of
the greatest living actors and actresses
and the greatest director so it's really
wonderful the one controversy of it was
that denzel washington obviously is not
scottish he's a black guy
so should a black guy be allowed to play
a white part and is this woke and is
this politically correct
the debate over colorblind casting is an
extremely complicated one
it's not a simple answer one way or the
other folks this has been a debate
that's gone on for decades one of the
great proponents of color blind casting
was a guy named bob it is a guy named
bob brewstein who was the founder of the
l repertory theater and
uh
is a sort of legend in the theater world
he's a white guy he's a big proponent of
color blind casting having black people
play white parts and
not taking into account of an actor's
ethnicity
august wilson who's probably the most
famous black playwright of the last
hundred years maybe the most famous
black playwright in american history he
hated colorblind casting he said black
people should not play white parts white
people should not play black parts this
is insane race
involves
lots of cultural aspects and it's you
can't suspend disbelief and you
shouldn't do it
there's also this double standard now
which is that white actors not white
actors are not allowed to play any
non-white parts and if they are there's
a big uproar and the woke people scream
about it
white actors are not even allowed to
voice non-white parts
the white actor who voiced apu on the
simpsons got got cancelled from the part
because you're not allowed to do that
anymore so yes there's a double standard
it's it's preposterous it's silly
however
if you can get past all of the stupid
woke stuff and just recognized that
denzel washington is one of the greatest
living actors and his performance in
this movie is just incredible then i
think
you can tune out all of the noise
furthermore you can say that shakespeare
is writing about not specific issues
only related to scotland but he's
writing about the human condition and
therefore it makes a lot more sense for
a black guy to play
that role even though it's a scottish
role really the play is about the human
condition whereas if you had denzel
washington starring in the the remake of
the sopranos that probably wouldn't make
a lot of sense what the sopranos is very
specifically about an italian-american
family so it wouldn't make sense to have
a non-italian actor play that part okay
that's a little bit of the controversy
around it the reason i even bring up the
movie though
is because the play is about
fate versus free will
and the movie joel cohen really brings
this out
macbeth
opens up the play one of the very first
things of the play is walking up and he
sees a bunch of witches and the witches
tell him his future and they say you're
going to become king but you're not
going to have a line of kings
and tells his partner banquo
you're not going to be king but your
kids are going to become king and
this is going to happen and this is
going to happen and macbeth is struck
with this and he says well hold on if
all of this is going first of all do i
believe these witches that that's really
going to happen and then he sees some
proof that some of their predictions
came true he says well okay if it's
going to happen then i guess i don't
need to do anything
he says if chance will have me king why
chance may crown me without my story i'm
not going to do anything about it but
then he does do something about he says
and mostly because his wife lady macbeth
is just an early version of hillary
clinton and she's this sort of wicked
political character who just
it impels him and convinces him to kill
the king and become king himself and so
he does participate in it but was that
always faded or did he really have free
choice and by the end he and his hillary
clinton wife go completely insane
and he's he's she becomes extremely
depressed he becomes very depressed he
can't sleep anymore because he killed
the king in his sleep he says he says
sleep no more macbeth does murder sleep
i'll never sleep again because one he
saw the king die in his sleep and two
because he's wracked by the moral
reality of what he's done
he's one of the most famous
lines of the entire place is tomorrow
and tomorrow and tomorrow creeps in this
petty pace from day to day to the last
syllable of recorded time and all our
yesterdays have lighted fools the way to
dusty death outbrief candle life's but a
walking shadow a poor player that struts
and frets his hour upon the stage and
then is heard no more it is a tale told
by an idiot full of sound and fury
signifying nothing that's what
a lot of people think life is today
that's what they think that it's all
just kind of a joke it's all just kind
of a farce a tale told by an idiot
signifying nothing our hopes our dreams
our loves our joys it's all just an
illusion man you know it's just
chemicals firing off in our brain
and it's just and by the way if you if
you don't like how you're feeling just
take a pill and then you'll feel better
or just do do some
other drugs or just go have sex with
somebody or go some you know sort of
casual sex or just go have a drink or
just go play video games or just plug
into the metaverse or just just give
yourself pleasure because that's all it
is it doesn't mean anything
but what macbeth and his wife realize
after they've committed this horrible
sin
is that the sin really does mean
something another one of the most famous
lines is you've got hillary clinton
there lady macbeth and she's saying out
damn spot out she's trying to rub out
the sp rub out the blood rub out what
she's done but she can't she can't
forget it macbeth can't sleep because he
can't forget what he actually did
because it does signify something it
does life actually does matter the
things we do there is a moral universe
and we're living in an age where we try
to blot all that out and we say that
everything is just about
power
at the left says that politics is just
different interest groups
and usually they push interest groups on
racial or sexual lines it's just them
vying for power and there's no sense and
there's no order and there's no truth
and there's no justice and there's no
goodness it's just interest and power
and frankly you have people on the right
saying almost the same thing it's
amazing that it's the conservatives who
for the past 30 years have said all life
is about is money and just boosting gdp
and cutting taxes and you do you and
we're not going to legislate morality
and don't yuck my young
and who's to say what's good i mean they
sound just like the liberals
and they all sound like
macbeth and lady macbeth and that's why
we live in a crappy country right now
because we need to recognize
that life actually does signify
something that's how we will have better
sleep that is how we will have a better
country that is how we will rub out that
damn spot is by recognizing that there's
a moral order there is sin there is
grace there is truth there is falsehood
there is goodness there is evil and
there is redemption if only we seek it
i'm so glad you like that clip stop
before you go anywhere
ring that bell please
i'd appreciate that you'll get the
notifications you'll find all the
wonderful videos that we put out and if
our friends here at youtube don't send
you those notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts for free you subscribe to
the michael knowles show you will get
the entire show uncensored too hot for
social media
check it out see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you